with the top Republican in the house
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy is
with us mr. leader thanks for being here
thanks for having the Wall Street
Journal moves this story today President
Trump in July phone call repeatedly
pressured the President to Ukraine of
Ukraine to investigate Democratic
presidential candidate Joe Biden's son
urging szalinski eight times to work
with Rudy Giuliani his personal lawyer
on a probe according to people familiar
with the matter do you have a problem
with that
well isn't we just as you said last
night we need to know more facts this is
just being written in The Wall Street
Journal what did we see last week with
the New York Times writing something
before had they have all the facts the
Director of National Intelligence the
Acting Director is going to be before
the Intel committee next Thursday in a
public hearing I think that will be the
appropriate time to find the information
out the president seemed to say hey
listen I can talk to world leaders how I
want to what you should look into this
you seemed when talking to reporters
today worried about the Joe Biden
Ukraine thing a lot more than you were
with the whistleblower things that where
well it's whether it's Ferrier here is
the president should be able to talk to
every world leader tonight he's going to
have the prime minister from Australia
it's important that we have
relationships but think for one moment
any conversation that you have who's
listening and why are all these other
people listening and only selectively
trying to put something out we have
watched this pattern before going after
this president because people disagree
with how the outcome of the election
took place I think this country has gone
through three years of this this part
has has got to stop the idea of what
they're going forward look I am
concerned about what I saw in a video
where Joe Biden himself telling the
Ukraine government that they are not
going to get money from the United
States if they don't fire a prosecutor
and he said you've got six hours and you
know what happened in six hours they
were fired that's Joe Biden's words
that's concerning to me if the President
did as it's being reported the
Washington Post has now matched the Wall
Street Journal and mentioned this
numerous times to the president of
Ukraine while the u.s. is considering
two hundred fifty million dollars in
lethal aid to Ukraine is that implicit
quid pro quo to get
investigation kick-started you don't
have any of the facts less wait till
next Thursday and let's go through the
appropriate channels have we not learned
this lesson how many times before I
guess what little question is if that
let's just say I'm not gonna speculate
that it happened but that is speculate
okay let me just say would it something
like that be a problem for you you know
what would be a problem for me is for me
to speculate without knowing the facts I
want my I want our president of the
United States to have relations with
every country I want our president to be
able to talk to those leaders and I
think it's inappropriate that all these
people are going to listen to these
conversations and selectively put
something out and then have one member
of Congress when everybody else the
other Republicans and Democrats in the
Intel committee but Adam Schiff to try
to make this political remember what
Adams shift said two years ago that he
had proof beyond circumstantial proof
and remember what he just put the
country through he put the country
through unbelievable pain for something
that he did not have the have any truth
to and he made us go through so much
let's not make that mistake again have
we not learned from the past do we not
understand that the Democrats did not
like this outcome do we not know that
Adam Schiff tip has proven wrong every
time before and is he doing this to the
country again right so you're asking for
facts yeah so is so are your colleagues
on Capitol Hill but they're being denied
access to the whistleblowers compliant
no they asked to handle this in the
appropriate manner that it's supposed to
just as the law says if he goes to the
inspector general which goes to the
inside the intelligence community yeah
normally in other cases the
whistleblower can come to Congress but
in an Intel community it can go to the
the inspector general would then go to
the to the DNI that a Director of
National Intelligence the Acting
Director McGuire he's handling this now
he's coming before Congress in a public
hearing of the Intel committee next
Thursday that's the appropriate way to
handle instead of leaking or putting
something out because they want to turn
the story to be different just like the
New York Times did last week you heard
the Rudy Giuliani back and forth about
no I didn't yes I did
ash the Ukrainians to investigate there
is a story here the New York Times that
the president goes after a lot did a
very big story about hunter Biden
working for this oligarch in a Oil
Company and and all of this background
to this investigation and there's their
there the reporters say there's more to
come
and what's your point that my point is
in in Joe Biden's own words he tells how
he pressured the Ukraine government that
they would not get funding from America
unless they fired a prosecutor it's
concerning to me is that prosecutor
investigating his son and he said you've
got six hours and within six hours they
fired him and Jill Bryan was proud of it
I've only learned to this by Joe Biden
telling us about it so you think the DNI
is going to come forward with
information I'm real concerned about
that and would it be interesting
politically if you wanted people not to
look at what Biden was doing to try to
bring something once again alleged
against this president as they've done
time and again because they do not like
an outcome of election and isn't it
interesting that Adams shift was behind
it again
who lied to the American public that he
had proof and put us through the
horrific two years so if you're you want
the proof would you advise the president
tonight at the state dinner to put out
the transcript of that call no what I
advise the president to do is build a
relationship with Australia because it's
so pivotal to our to our point for the
next century
we've dealing with China and everywhere
else and you know what I think this
presidents been through enough he's
proven he could do the job and why are
people listening to his calls and
selectively putting something out for
political gain let this president govern
this nation he's proved he could do it
economically this cut this world is
safer because of President Trump and I
want to continue to be that and I want
him to have relationships with other
countries I want to ask you just a quick
lightning round with all the GOP
retirements is there any chance of
winning back the house there's not only
a chance it's gonna happen look what
just happened in North Carolina and you
know what's gonna happen when we win
back the house the Republican Party's
only be stronger and let me give you one
point the only retirement I'm afraid
that happened was will hurt but you know
what when you look at all the others two
years ago Ted Poe retired and I was very
concerned about that but you know who
won dancringe
the Navy SEAL Dan Crenshaw has an
amazing following today but we have from
Yong Kim - Wesley hunt a West Point
graduate flew Apaches the number of
candidates that we have we haven't seen
in the past and if I was Democrats I'd
be afraid because there are 31 Democrats
who sit in seats the president Trump
carried and in that race in North
Carolina nine in 2018 we want it by 900
votes we just want it by 4,100 that
simple 2% change it's 13 seats on its
own all right a little bit more
lightning mr. leader here we go
full-blown impeachment effort would that
help your re-election efforts in the
house I don't look at politics but I
think it only hurt the country and
Nadler that's all he wants to do but
nobody else cares for it so I think it's
a stupid thing to move his policies
leadership in jeopardy with natalier
Cicilline
the squad all calling for impeachment
Nancy Pelosi is the speaker but in
speaker and name only she does not have
the power they run the floor you met
with Mark Zuckerberg today the inside
scoop well we had a great conversation
when it comes to privacy I have a real
concern about privacy Democrats want to
break up companies or make them
utilities which is terrible for America
what I wanted to do protect your data
let you move your data and let you
delete your data and if they want to
monetize it make sure the person that
the data is what it is and give them a
piece of the the resources that you're
able to grow mr. leader we appreciate
your time enjoy the state dinner thank
you